- You look so freaking cute.
- Thank you.
- Like beautiful, all the things.
The nails with it.
- It's got pockets.
- Yeah, the nail game makes it
a little more rock and roll.
I don't even wear a dress
without pockets anymore.
I don't have time for that designer.
- [Sarah] No.
- Yeah, I love a pocket.
- You just always need your things on you.
- Yes, did you have one
in your wedding dress?
- I did.
- Because Congrats.
You had pockets?
- I had pockets.
- [Kelly] I love that.
Congrats on your wedding.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
- [Kelly] That's so awesome.
- [Sarah] It was so fun.
- [Kelly] I love, your
"Modern Family" co-star,
Jesse Tyler Ferguson,
he married y'all, right?
- [Sarah] Yeah, he did.
- [Kelly] Was that the
plan The whole time?
- [Sarah] So, Ty Burrell was originally
supposed to marry us.
- Yeah.
- [Sarah] He's, he's already ordained...
- To be an officiant.
I don't wanna really say minister,
but, so he was supposed to
and there was a, an emergency,
he wasn't able to make it,
like a week before the
wedding we found out.
And so, I sent a text message to Jesse
and, because we're
obviously very, very close.
- Yeah.
- And I was like...
- Please.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Fake TV uncle, real life friend,
Tony Award winning, Jesse Tyler Ferguson.
- [Kelly] You can do this.
- Will you marry us?
- Yeah.
- And he so graciously like, did it and...
- Did he have to get
ordained like, really fast?
(audience applauds)
- Yeah, we did, like, we
did this like crazy process,
like online, he got ordained.
- Yeah.
- And the entire wedding,
he kept flashing people his clergy badge.
(Kelly laughs)
- It's real.
- He was wearing it on the
inside like, "Look at me".
(Kelly laughs)
- I love that, is it true that
you threatened your husband
if he didn't cry at your wedding?
- Yes.
- I love...
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Yes.
- You wanted real emotion, you wanted,
you wanted to go there.
- I, I actually
specifically, verbatim said,
"If I don't see you crying
when I walk down the aisle,
I'm turning around".
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- [Kelly] Oh, and he did.
- [Sarah] And he did cry.
(audience gasps)
- Aw, I love that.
So, you've said that your
husband is a good communicator,
so...
- Yes.
- [Kelly] How has that helped?
I'm sure that's helped immensely,
in your relationship, right?
- Oh, immensely.
I would, I've always been the
communicator in relationships
and I remember our
first fight that we had,
which wasn't even a big deal.
I got so frustrated, I stomped upstairs
and I slammed the door
and then, I was like,
"What is happening?"
I am not the person that
does this, this is crazy.
Like, he just wants to talk about it.
- Yeah.
- And I think that
that's just, it's so key,
it's so cliche, but it's so
key for a healthy relationship
to be able to communicate,
know how to fight, know each other's...
- To know how to
communicate and then listen.
- And then listen.
- Yeah.
- And you know, to really understand
how one another feels at times.
It's not just a love language thing
of words of appreciation,
or anything like that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's, you know, we're very opposite
in how we are when we're upset
or angry about something.
- As we all are, yeah.
- Everyone's an individual and so like,
he likes to be left
alone and I like to be...
- [Kelly] You wanna talk it out.
- Held like a baby.
- Like a baby.
(Kelly laughs)
- I want to be the joey in the pouch.
Just like, put me in there.
- Yeah, he just doesn't wanna be touched.
- And he doesn't wanna be touched,
he doesn't wanna be looked at.
He's just like, "I'm
going through my stuff,
I'll figure it out in my head.
Everything is fine".
So, like that's something
that we've learned
about each other that we work on every day
to be able to make sure
that we give each other
what the other person needs.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's great.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Well, congratulations.
- [Sarah] Thank you.
- Great partner, that's awesome.
So, did your family speak at the wedding?
Did anybody get up and say anything?
- Yeah, so we had our rehearsal dinner,
my brother gave the sweetest speech.
- See, that's when I would cry.
- It was so, every, there
wasn't a, a dry eye.
- Yeah.
- In the...
- And if you see one, you
know that person's dead
in their...
- Yeah, yeah.
- In their heart.
Yeah, you're like...
- Are you gonna murder me?
- There's something wrong with you.
- I think you're gonna murder me.
(Kelly and Sarah laugh)
- That's cool, though.
- [Sarah] Yeah, it was amazing.
I mean, we are like five years apart.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, we have this thing
and he said it, he was like,
"Nobody makes my sibling cry but me".
(Kelly laughs)
And that's like, how we were.
- So much in that statement.
It's like, "I'll punch anyone
that makes my brother cry,
but like..."
- I can do it.
- But I can do it, a thousand times over.
- Yeah.
- And it was just, it was
so sweet and Wells' sister
and her husband spoke
and they wore onesies.
The ones, I got them animal
onesies for Christmas in 2017,
I thought that they had thrown them out,
donated them, whatever.
And all of a sudden we look over
and they were doing a
speech in their onesies
and I was so, it was so
sweet, I love it so much.
- Oh, I love that family, that's fun.
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- Yeah, usually people
aren't like that at weddings,
that's cool.
- Yeah, it was great.
- Yeah, yeah.
They're just like stuffier.
- They just like, disappeared
for like a second...
- I love that, they're like,
"So, this is how we're
gonna present our speech".
- Yes, exactly.
(Sarah laughs)
- So, your family shared
a very small apartment
in New York whenever
you were little, right?
- Yes.
- Was that, was it, I mean,
it kind of seems like hard times,
but it also seems kind of
cool, because you're all like
it's very cool and tight and,
and your family's like all together.
That's kind of cool.
- Yeah and as a child you don't...
- [Kelly] You don't realize.
- You don't know the difference, you know?
Whether you're staying in
a 5,000 square foot house
or a 300 square foot apartment, you know?
- Yeah.
- Like it's, it was,
it was amazing and fun
and the building had so much
history, which was really cool.
Like, I remember singing "Annie" nonstop,
because I was auditioning for it.
And so, I would go out
onto the fire escapee
and like, get some air and like,
really feel like an orphan
in the 30's in New York City.
- Did your neighbors hate you?
(Kelly chuckles)
- They were actually so sweet.
- Oh.
- Like, they would applaud and
then like a week would go by
and they'd like yell up like,
"Hey, did you book Annie?
Like, what's going on?"
- Oh, my gosh.
- It was so sweet.
- So...
- [Sarah] But then we had like,
my cat brought me a
birthday present one time
and jumped up on the bed, went to pet him,
it stopped after about an
inch, turned on the light
and it was a mouse's head.
So, then there's that as well.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Welcome to New York, yep, yeah.
- Yes.
- Rats and mice, yeah.
- Rats and mice and people
asking if you booked "Annie".
- I love that you, asking
if you booked "Annie",
very New York, all of that.
- [Sarah] Very New York.
- I just love that like,
I thought you were
gonna say they hated it,
because I lived in an
apartment in Columbus
when I was little and I, you
know, "The Little Mermaid".
(Kelly hums)
- Oh, yeah.
- Okay, I thought this was my moment.
I just always would go out on the balcony
and sing that part.
- Just that?
- And then revert and
go, "Just keep singing".
And like play it out,
like the whole thing.
And my neighbors hated us.
(Kelly laughs)
- I can't.
- But I didn't care, I just kept singing.
(Kelly chuckles)
- You're welcome...
- So, I love that your
neighbors were supportive.
- They were, they were so sweet.
- Yeah, I was, that's
really nice, that's nice.
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- So, your father's an actor as well,
so the apple doesn't fall from the tree.
I hear he's on Broadway right now, right?
- Yes.
- That's exciting, what's he doing?
- He is doing "Harry Potter
and the Cursed Child"
on Broadway.
(audience applauds)
- Do you? I love "Harry Potter".
Do you love "Harry Potter"?
- My dad's Dumbledore.
- No way.
- I know.
(Sarah hums)
- I know, oh, my God.
Did you read them when you were younger?
- Oh, yes.
- Me too.
- I, I read them.
I actually introduced
"Harry Potter" to my family.
I found it at like a book fair at school.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was obsessed with them.
And then so, my brother was too little
to read those massive books.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, my dad would read them out loud
and would do voices for everyone and...
- Pregame.
(Kelly chuckles)
- [Sarah] It was, it was great, yeah.
He had the full 360,
it was, it was amazing.
And he's so, so, so good.
- Oh, that's so cool, Dumbledore.
- [Sarah] Dumbledore.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
(audience chuckles)
- Oh, my gosh, all right.
So you, you've spent time in
Berlin for your new project?
- Yeah.
- And you had a roommate, right?
- Yes, I did.
(Kelly chuckles)
It was a studio apartment
and it was at this very, very,
very old building in Berlin.
A lot of, probably terrible
things happened there.
And I was moving in and I
was putting my stuff in this,
in this dresser and all of
a sudden I smelled perfume
and I was like, "What is going on?
Is this like such a fancy place
that they push perfume through the vents?"
And then, I very quickly
realized that I had a roommate
and I feel like she had
been there since like,
I wanna say the 40's and...
- You mean like a ghost?
- Yeah, I named her Olga.
(audience gasps)
- And you stayed in it, did you stay?
- Yes.
- What is happening?
- We created a relationship,
like she was very sweet.
Her name was not Olga, I did ask her that,
but I couldn't figure out her actual name.
So, I asked if it was
okay to call her Olga
and she was like, "Yeah, whatever".
- What?
(audience and Sarah laugh)
Like, I'm, I'm freaking,
I'm so terrified of stuff
like that, not terrified,
I just don't even wanna know
it exists, if it exists.
Like, and you're saying it
exists which terrifies me.
There's just enough
going on in this realm.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] I don't wanna have
to worry about another one.
That's insane and it
didn't scare you at all.
Have you been like that,
like since you were a kid?
- [Sarah] Oh, yes.
My mom taught me how to read
tarot cards when I was a kid,
she reads palms.
- I'm obsessed with reading tarot cards,
I think they're so fun.
- It's, it's great.
- Yeah.
- It's, it's amazing.
- Sometimes really dead on.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I mean, if you put like
the right energy into it
and ask the right questions,
you can really be able to,
it's not a future teller by any means,
but you can really be able
to understand the situation
where other people are coming from.
But yeah, no, when I
was a, when I was a kid,
I saw dead people all the time.
- What in the world?
- Yeah.
I can't see them anymore.
- Okay, see that's
what, that's my problem,
see, I'm a very open person
and that's what scares me,
because I'm, and I, I
literally let people like,
let go sort of, I'm like,
I walk in somewhere,
and somebody says, I'm like,
"I'm really cool if you're here.
Like, but like, just don't show yourself".
(Sarah laughs)
Like I'm, we can both be
here, we don't have to know.
- I don't wanna know what you look like.
- Yeah, I'm like, "I don't wanna see you".
I'm like, because I'm such an open person,
I feel like they, it would happen to me
and then I would die.
- Oh, no.
(Sarah chuckles)
- Yeah, I would die.
- You just have to be
able to protect yourself
and it's good.
- I am not that person,
I just like to avoid it.
So, okay, let's talk about your new show.
So, it's part of the "Pitch
Perfect" franchise, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, were you a fan?
Were you just a super fan?
- Such a fan.
- Me too, I love it.
- I think I grew up in a choir
like it, so it's like, yeah.
- Oh, yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- I mean Jason Moore, who
directed the first one,
I did "Shrek the Musical"
with him in New York.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And he directed, so
I was such a fan of it.
And of course Adam, I know
Adam from "Modern Family"
so it's such a, an
amazing thing to be able
to be a part of the whole franchise,
because I love everyone
that is a part of it.
- Yeah.
- But to be able to sing again,
I haven't sung in such a long time.
- I was gonna say that's such a cool thing
that you can do both.
What's this plot about?
Like what, what is this story about,
since it's part of the franchise?
- So, Bumper is still
working at the university
and gets a call from,
if anybody remembers Peter
Cromer from the "Pitch Perfect",
I think it was two,
from Das Sound Machine.
And he calls him, tells him
that he's famous in Berlin
and that he's going to be
the next biggest thing.
So, Bumper, Adam DeVine
moves to Berlin on a whim
and I play Peter's assistant
and she's this weird, quirky, bubbly,
but very, very weird person.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Who is really shy...
- That's fun to play.
- And is like a, a very
much a perfectionist.
And so, she doesn't want
people to hear her sing
until she knows it's perfect,
which I can very much relate to.
- I was gonna say, are you that person?
- I am that person.
I am way too much of a control
freak and a perfectionist.
So, I'm very much related to that.
And yeah, it's all about Bumper trying
to win a thing called,
German Unity Day concert
for a record label.
- Oh, my God, I'm gonna love it.